like many schools St geneves in Belfast
has been doing all it can to reintegrate
pupils after the pandemic but for some
that's been a struggle so this year the
schools introduced a safe space The
Haven for students with special needs or
social issues to find rest bite and a
friendly ear but such Innovations cost
money and funding decisions have been on
hold since the collapse in 2022 of
Northern Ireland's devolved government
we need um improvements made to our
building to make these adjustments they
don't happen overnight if we don't have
that funding those children are at home
waiting to come to a place that we have
secured for them free trade policy in
London on Thursday UK politicians
approved the deal set to restore
Northern Ireland's po sharing executive
and release more than $4 billion of
funding for its public
services but at the same time another
strike was underway in Belfast this time
public transport workers trying to
ensure their demands for pay Rises are
met until then the government really
funds to give us our pay rise which
we're fully entitled to not just us all
public sector workers then we'll
continue on if you ask people about the
real world impact of the last nearly two
years without a functioning government
almost all of them will say it's the
Health Service on almost every metric
especially waiting times Northern
Ireland's Health Service lags far behind
the rest of the UK Alan Stout is a
family doctor and a senior figure in the
British Medical Association here he says
his patients regularly endure agonizing
weights for hospital treatment most of
them are a year plus uh certainly for
routine or urgent red flags are slightly
different um but you know some of our
elderly patients for example who need
joint Replacements they could wait 5 six
years to see a surgeon long-term
problems within Northern Ireland's
Public Services have been worsened by
this crippling bout of political
deadlock the politicians about to resume
their duties know that to a large extent
they be judged by how quickly they can
start to put them right Harry foret Al
jazer
[Music]
Belfast make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer